Hey everybody hope you're doing well. In this chapter I will be teaching you the most mechanical gold training strategy. So previously I made a video on gold and it was only for the people who could trade the Asian session, right? But this one is gonna work in London session and I've been getting a lot of requests. So this chapter of this course is gonna explain each and everything about the strategy. So make sure you wash your hands.
the end so you don't miss anything. Now, my goal always has been to you're
simplified trading, all right? I don't want you guys to be looking for daily bias
and doing these top down analysis. Yes, of course, they they have a little bit
of advantage over mechanical strategies, but this strategy about to teach you
right now broke trust me. It works every single day. Like there is no day that it
won't work. Alright, so what exactly is the strategy? Right? So we know that the London session
starts at 3 am near time. Alright, so let's assume that this is the London session open. Right?
Now all you have to do is go to the 15 minute timeframe. Right? And the very first
Ferval
The London session.
You are waiting for price to create some form of a Fervalic app.
The first Fervalic app that forms during the London session.
Remember that.
So let's assume that we have this Fervalic app formed around here.
So all I'm actually waiting for is to price for the price to inverse it.
And what I mean by this is I want the price to close below it.
Okay?
So the entire strategy is basically how this is how it goes.
So during London, mark out the first strategy that forms and then wait for it to get in
first. All right, so remember this. Now, all you are waiting for to do from here onwards when
the fair value gap gets in first is you're taking your entry on the retest. You're going for one
to two and you are targeting some form of liquidity, right? And basically you're putting your stop
above the bodies. So this is your entry. So let's suppose that this is weak, right? So this part
of this price is the wig. But then over here are the bodies. So you're going to put your
star pair not above the wig but above the bodies. Literally this is literally it's going to work
every single day guys. All right. Now it works for Forex as well. But there are some other methods
for it. I'm going to teach that in the upcoming chapters. But for now this is the best goal
strategy for the London session. Right? And similarly, if you look at it here, you know,
we have this London open here at three, right? And I'm going to give you guys some examples
that don't worry. I'm going to explain all of the other things as well. You can see
that we have the fresh property gap that forms, right? The very first, all right? You have
to put entire focus on that fairly gap. And then you can see that whenever price in
versus it is when you take your entry from the we test. So what is a high probability setup
in this for this strategy? So let's assume that price created some form of liquidity
before going into London open. And we create a fairly gap, the very first fairly gap
that forms during the London session. And you have these equal highs, liquidity level, somewhere
around here. Now this is the high probability setup. So when price in versus that
fresh probability gap, you can actually take you into on the retest or on the body closure.
So if the body closes slightly above it, then you can take your entry straight away.
But if it's gone way far up ahead and you know, you think that your stop was going to be big,
then you take your entry from the retest, put your stop below the bodies, and then you can target
easily target these equal highs over here. Now what if the liquidity is swept before you get your
entry right and this is what's going to make the setup low probability because we have already reached
our target but rest assured even if the liquidity is swept there might be some high time from
liquidity investing above here that the price will take out. All you need to do is just look for
the very first fair value gap that firms during the London session and then you're waiting for it
to get inversed and then you're looking to take your entry from the retest or, um, or,
or you know, just entering state away.
Now, key thing to note is that if there's some form of news, right, are you just want to
avoid that setup and wait till 15 minutes pass, right, after news?
You do not want to trade before news because what's going to happen is price is going
to do something like this, right?
It's going to just mess up everything.
So you want to avoid the high impact news.
So by now this should be clean, perfectly clean, right?
Now there is another way to improve the windward and that is by marking some form of high
time from PDRA and price dips into that PDRA and then it reverses the fresh trail you
get that from, right?
Or it's simply just swept some form of liquidity here, right?
And once it sweeps that and it reverses the very first fair body gap of the London session,
then you can take your entry.
setup is insanely powerful guys and I'm gonna give you guys some examples now and you are going to
tag me before I move to the examples if you're watching this on YouTube I want to let you know that
my new course is coming out very soon so if you want free access to my course you have to
enroll into my current course right now otherwise if you don't do it and the new course releases
is gonna be priced at a different level but now if you enroll into my current course you can
and actually get the entire access to my discord
where I have the course videos for absolutely free.
So let's go on to the examples now.
All right guys, so here is example one
and we're waiting for the London Open
and at 3am we have the London Open.
So now we are waiting for a fairly good formation.
And straight away what do we have?
We have a fairly good that formed around here.
So now we're waiting for price to inverse it, right?
And you can see we also set some form of liquidity here.
So now we're waiting for price to inverse.
And right away we have the inversion.
So I'm going to take my entry on the retails.
I'm going to put my stop right below these bodies.
Not below the weight, but below the body.
And probably we can target one to two here.
And I can leave some runners till here.
But I usually go for one to two and that's it.
So you can see we get our entry on the retest and the take profit level was hit
and then price you know it eventually it went up to that liquidity level and it
took it out. Although I would always go for one to two and you can see how
price just went up ahead and reacted from this auto block here. Push down below
well if you had you stopped below the week then maybe you could have but you would
still be close at break even. So it's best to always take a profit at 1 to 2.
Let me give you guys some more examples. Alright guys so here is example 2 and
this is the London Open. So I'm waiting for everybody to get formation. And
just around here we have the very first for everybody to get up of the London
session. So the London session is from 3am to 7am. So I'm waiting for
price to inverse it right away but do we have? We have inverse it. And we have
these equal highs resting around this area and we have also swept some form of
liquidity here. So I'm just gonna long here put my job below the body here and
I can go for one to two. I don't care. Alright, I'm just gonna go break even at one
to one so I'm rich free. So let's assume what happened here. You can see that at
at this point I would go break even right but since 1 to 1 yeah so I'm just going to
hold till 1 to 2 and eventually it goes up ahead and takes out this high over here as well.
So you can see how we inverse the very first level you get and we had this liquidity resting
above here.
It is not necessary these two steps right the liquidity sweep and the the resting liquidity
is not necessary but it's gonna improve the win rate always always gonna always
improve the win rate but if you want to keep things as mechanical as possible just
wait for the first for a little gap to get inversed and take your entry
bro it's it's really really not that hot and if I go just around here you can
see that we have this fairly gap the very first for a little gap that formed
during the London and notice what happened we had this liquidity level
resting around here right and we swept this liquidity here and then we
inversed the fairly gap the first row of the gap of the London session shot
position right here stop right above the bodies here and a beautiful one to two
wrist to the wall right away so two examples in one clip let me give you guys some
examples. Alright guys so here is another example and we have the London open
here so I'm waiting for a fair value gap formation and we do have it
around here. So notice two things now. We have swept this liquidity these
relative equal highs over here, right? We also swept this high over here. That's
perfect and we have these equal lows resting around this level. So
So what does this directly tell you that we're going to inverse it and then we're going
to push down like crazily.
All right.
So right away, what do we have?
We have inversion, entry on the retest stops above the bodies of the highest wick.
Right?
So this is the highest wick.
The bodies.
All right.
Because if price goes here, there's 99% chance it's going to take out this level.
So just don't bother.
And one to two.
Let's see how this plays out.
We get our retest.
And we push down and the take profit was hit.
Notice how the bodies were respected
inside this inversion.
All right.
This is all algorithm bro.
Like it's insane how well this shit works.
All right, so over here, you can see bro,
it just happens every single day.
So this is the London session start, right?
No fair value gap, no fair value gap,
and then out of nowhere, we have a fair value gap.
We sweep the liquidity here, right?
And we have this insane amount of liquidity resting here, right?
And you can just see how well it works.
So inversion, entry on the retest,
or actually I would enter here
because it's just weight close, weight close.
And my stop, you can see this is the highest weight.
I would put it somewhere around here.
And wow, insane guys.
It's just, it's incredible how well it works.
All right.
All right guys, so here is the last example.
And this is the London Open.
So we are waiting for your fairly good formation.
And right away, we have the very first fairly good
that forms during the London session.
And over here, you can see we have equal highs.
and those were swept as well.
And then we have this sorry,
Asian low as I would draw on liquidity.
And you can also see we tapped into this volume imbalance here.
So there are just so many confluence
is telling you to shot this pro.
And then we have the inversion here, right?
And on the retest, you can see,
straight away, stops right above the bodies.
But since the week is not that big,
I can actually put it here.
It's no problem.
All right.
I would go for one to two, but let's see how this plays out.
So we got our entry and price just melted.
So the key thing to note here is, guys, if you really
want this model to work every single day, number one,
look for liquidity sweep.
All right.
This is key because it's not like necessary.
But I showed you so many examples where price
strips some form of significant liquidity equal highs,
equal lows, and then the push is insane.
So look for liquidity soup, right?
And or price goes into some form of key level here.
And then clear draw on liquidity.
You have clear draw on liquidity.
this example we had this LRLR something and I don't want to use complicated words
it's just the karate bro all right a trendline liquidity what I want to call it
clear draw liquidity and then you are waiting for the first inversion of first
for everybody gap that forms in London this is literally your bread and butter
like it works so well that you have no idea. Alright now some days what's gonna
happen is so let me just show you here. Okay actually we inverse this here as
well this was a tiny little fair value gap and you can see that we formed it at
three right so sometimes the fair value gap is gonna form at exactly at three
So the the second candle if it's at three then it's acceptable
However, if the second candle is at 245 so fairbody gap is off three candles right one two three now
I want the second candle to be at three a.m. Exact. This should be the one
All right if it doesn't form here then I'm looking for another probably gap to form
But since what people would do is they would consider this as the first fairbody gap and I do not want to see
this. Why? Because the second candle formed at 245. So this is not the forever you got
the form during the London. However, this one right here, it formed right during London.
So yeah guys, this is practically the entire model and you can see that we had this inverse
for already got up here as well. And prices, dip, low it, bro. Let me show you guys a losing
trade. Hopefully I can find it. So we inverse the first
trail of the gap here. Oh my god. I'm just going to end the video when I find a
losing the losing trade. This is the first trail of the gap. Oh my god. In
verse, it just went up. There's there any fair value gap. There's no fair value
gap. So we just simply skip the day. This is the first trail of the gap, but
didn't close no inversion. Dude, there's not a single losing trade bro. Come on, I gotta find
one losing trade bro. Oh my god, there's another inverse, look at it, look at it. Oh my god,
this, this isn't saying, please, please, please, I need to find a losing trade. Otherwise, I won't
be able to end the video. Okay, this is some form of a losing, I don't know, I just, I just want to
want to losing trade bro even though it was way late in the
London and this is the first row where you got their form.
Nah this is not a good losing trade.
I want to see a better losing trade. Oh my god.
Wow dude dude dude guys guys I'm telling you.
Okay. This shit is insane. Look at this.
All right. There's no losing trade bro. Hopefully here.
Hopefully hopefully hopefully hopefully hopefully.
Alright, so you might have noticed one thing.
If the friendly gap forms way too late, so in the sixth hour, so from 6am to 7, it becomes
low probability.
Even though we had a beautiful reaction from here, and we took out the liquidity, anyways,
I want to see a losing trade guys, I'm losing my mind over here.
Come on, give me a losing trade.
This is the first favorite thing I got in the forms in the London.
sweep liquidity and we take out this level. This is insanity. Hopefully here. Hopefully we
here have a losing trade. First in verse. Oh my god. Guys, I think the video is never going
to end. There's no further gap here. Actually, hopefully guys, guys, I finally found a losing
No freaking way. There's not a fair way gap. Oh my god. I'm losing my mind. I'm losing my
mind guys. There's no probability gap here. Okay, finally, bro. Finally, god damn it. And
the reason why we lost this trade was we didn't sweep this significant liquidity over
here. All right guys, this is gonna be the end. We finally found the losing trade. I hope
Hope you guys leave a subscribe and if you're watching it in this code I hope you guys enjoyed
watching this and learned something from it.
I'll see you guys in the next chapter.